BRIAN: ALL RIGHT.
SO AS TEXAS FIGHTS A RISE IN
COVID-19 CASES THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE DEPLOYING 580 SUPPORT
AND MEDICAL SUPPORT PERSONNEL TO
HELP OUT.
HERE TO HELP ON THE GROUND
DOCTOR UREA.
WHAT CITIES HAVE YOU SEEN AND
WHAT INFORMATION CAN YOU RELAY?
>> SO I WORK IN AUSTIN, AND I
WORK SOMETIMES IN HOUSTON AND
OUTSIDE OF ANTONIO.
BETWEEN ALL OF THOSE CITIES AND
I HAVE COLLEAGUES ACROSS TEXAS.
THINGS ARE GETTING BUSY
EVERYWHERE.
IN EVERY MAIN CITY IN TEXAS WE
ARE STRETCHING.
OUR ERs ARE STRETCHING OUR
BULGING AT THE SCENE.
THINGS ARE GETTING BUSY NORMAL
ER PATIENTS LET ALONE ALL THE
COVID PATIENTS COME IN.
IT’S BEEN TERRIFYING.
EVEN THE PATIENTS WHO COME IN
FOR NON-COVID RELATED THINGS
LIKE A TRAUMA PATIENT, FOR
EXAMPLE, WE END UP FINDING OUT
THAT THEY HAVE COVID WHILE THEY
ARE IN THE ER.
AND SO THINGS GET VERY, VERY
HECTIC AT THAT POINT BECAUSE
THESE ARE INFECTIOUS
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES THAT WE
VERY MUCH WORRY ABOUT.
BRIAN: SO IF SOMEONE TESTS
POSITIVE, THEY DON’T GO FOR
HOSPITALIZATION UNLESS THEY
BEGIN TO FAIL, CORRECT?
>> CORRECT.
YEAH.
SOMEBODY COMES INTO THE
HOSPITAL.
WE ARE NOT TESTING THEM UNLESS
THEY NEED TO BE ADMITTED.
BUT AS CAN YOU IMAGINE A LOT OF
TRAUMA PATIENTS, A LOT OF
PRESURGICAL PATIENTS, A LOT OF
PATIENTS BEING ADMITTED FOR
OTHER THINGS WILL NEED IMAGING
AND ON THAT IMAGING WE MIGHT SEE
OH MY GOSH THEY HAVE COVID IN
THEIR LUNGS NOW WE HAVE TO
ATTACK THIS WHOLE SITUATION VERY
DIFFERENTLY.
BRIAN: I UNDERSTAND HOUSTON IS
SO BAD THE MAYOR THERE IS
CALLING FOR ANOTHER LOCKDOWN.
HOW BAD IS IT IN HOUSTON?
I HEARD A WEEK AGO THEY WERE
RUNNING OUT OF ICU BEDS.
>> THINGS ARE PRETTY BAD IN
HOUSTON RIGHT NOW.
I MEAN, THEY ARE WORKING ON BED
MANAGEMENT.
THEY ARE STRETCHING.
THEY ARE AT THEIR LIMIT.
SOME HOSPITALS ARE ALREADY WELL
PAST THAT LIMIT.
WHERE WE ARE TRYING TO SHIFT
PATIENTS BETWEEN HOSPITALS TO
MAKE ROOM.
THEY HAVE TO KEEP THESE PATIENTS
IN CERTAIN AREAS.
THEY CAN’T JUST ADMIT A COVID
POSITIVE PATIENT ANYWHERE.
SO IT’S BEEN VERY DIFFICULT.
I MEAN, THEY ARE EVEN HAVING TO
USE THE CHILDREN’S HOSPITAL FOR
BARK UP FOR ADULT PATIENTS.
THAT’S PRETTY REMARKABLE.
THAT’S A RED FLAG.
BRIAN: I WATCHED -- OVER THE
WEEKEND THE MAIN DIFFERENCE IS
FROM NOW FROM THE SPRING YOU
KNOW SO MUCH MORE ABOUT IT.
VENTILATORS ARE REALLY A LAST
STEP NOW BECAUSE SO FEW RECOVER
FROM IT AND REMDESIVIR HAS BEEN
EFFECTIVE.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL ME HAS BEEN
EFFECTIVE AND ARE PEOPLE
RECOVERING?
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY.
OUR MANAGEMENT HAS CHANGED OF
THIS DISEASE.
WE HAVE LEARNED SO MUCH ABOUT
IT.
WE ARE INTUBATING PATIENTS
LATER.
WE ARE USING BLOOD THINNERS.
WE ARE USING REMEDIES SEAR WHEN
HOSPITALS HAVE IT.
NOT EVERY PATIENT WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT MEDICATION.
THERE ARE VERY STRICT GUIDELINES
WHEN WE CAN START IT.
OUR MANAGEMENT OVERALL HAS
CHANGED WITH ANY NEW INFECTIOUS
DISEASE AS WE GO ALONG THROUGH
THE COURSE.
WE ARE BETTER AT MANAGING IT IN
THESE PATIENTS AND ARE DOING A
BETTER JOB IN GETTING MORE
PATIENTS ACROSS THE FINISH LINE
BUT WHAT WE’RE WORRIED ABOUT
RIGHT NOW IS THE COLLATERAL
DAMAGE WHEN YOU OVERWHELM A
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM WITH ANYTHING,
ESPECIALLY AN INFECTIOUS DISEASE
LIKE WE ARE RIGHT NOW, YOU DON’T
JUST WORRY ABOUT THE PATIENTS
DYING FROM COVID, THEN IT’S
PATIENTS DYING OF COMPLETELY
OTHERWISE PREVENTABLE CAUSES OF
DEATH.
YOU KNOW, APPENDICITIS, HEART
ATTACKS, STROKES EVERYTHING GETS
AFFECTED WHEN A HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM IS OVERWHELMED.
THE MORTALITY OF ALL OF THAT HAS
TO BE INCLUDED WHEN WE LOOK AT,
YOU KNOW, OUR MORAL COMPASS OF
HOW MUCH WE ARE WILLING TO
SACRIFICE AND TOLERATE BEFORE WE
STEP.
IN.
BRIAN: REAL QUICK, ANYTHING ELSE
THAT YOU NEED BECAUSE THEY
ARE -- LOOKING FOR MORE POP-UP
HOSPITALS, TENTS, CONVERSION OF
STADIUMS?
>> I THINK RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
BACKUP PLANS IN PLACE AROUND THE
CITY TO AND EVERY CITY I KNOW IN
SAN ANTONIO AS WELL.
WE DON’T WANT TO GET TO THAT
POINT WHERE WE ARE OUTSIDE OF
THE HOSPITAL.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE YOU DON’T
HAVE ACCESS TO EVERYTHING ELSE
THE HOSPITAL HAS.
THE RADIOLOGY, THE BLOOD WORK,
EVERYTHING ELSE GETS
TRANSFERRED.
SO, WE ARE REALLY WORKING ON
PERSONNEL RIGHT NOW, HEALTHCARE
WORKERS.
FRONT LINE WORKERS, RESPIRATORY
THERAPISTS, THAT’S REALLY WHAT
OUR MANPOWER IS OUR PHYSICIANS
STAFFING IS OKAY RIGHT NOW.
THAT’S TEETERING, WE WILL SEE
HOW THAT GOES.
BUT IT’S REALLY THE NURSES AND
THE RESPIRATORY THERAPISTS.
WE ARE ALSO SURGE STAFFING FROM
AROUND THE STATE.
WE WILL SEE HOW MUCH WE CAN
HANDLE BEFORE THIS GETS OUT OF
CONTROL.
BRIAN: THANK YOU SO MUCH.